why why and how did gym launch go from
you know 200 000
a month in its first month to 1.5
million within seven months
per month right and then 2.2 million
four months after that
literally just straight through yeah so
the simple answer is there isn't one
thing right it was a confluence of
variables if
you look at like uh warren buffett and
charlie munger they call it the
lollapalooza effect but it's basically
when you have
multiple kind of flywheels or virtuous
cycles that stack on top of each other
and then the sum
is much greater than the parts right the
first big one is that when we entered
the marketplace
uh there weren't as many there weren't
as many gym gurus first off
right just right off the bat there
weren't as many number two
there weren't nearly as many marketing
on facebook like we were the first one
like one among the first ones
uh to kind of come in i think there were
two guys i can think of who were
marketing before
like timing timing right off the bat
there was like the biggest
timing was one of them right the other
piece and timing had multiple components
one is the competition
right the other piece of it was facebook
itself
right when we started dude the average
gym that worked with us made 28 000
in the first 30 days that was the
average
not the like half of them did more than
that
right that's absurd that's absurd right
and so as far as their experiences are
concerned they pay a thousand dollars to
start
they get a 14 day like we give them we
have 14 days free because they'd have to
make the money to make the next
next purchase right and then it was a
thousand dollars a week after that for
16 weeks
so by the time they made their third
thousand dollar payment
they'd already made 28 000 and paid
three
watch in an ad spend they'd only spend a
thousand bucks
so we had created a money printing
machine
and so yes uh we had referrals out the
ass
like absolutely like our dad our top our
top
gym referred us 52 clients our second
highest gym referred us 32 clients
and those are coaching clients who all
had 30k ltv so like i had two guys who
sent me like two and a half million
bucks like two and we had
like a hundred different gyms who
referred us business right wow
so like that was obviously a big piece
of it
um i'd say those are probably the
biggest ones
you